this is a production of Cornell
University topic for today is I chose
the words carefully when I named it
I don't really study climate change not
really interested in measuring the
minutiae of carbon and things like that
I am on the other end of it and that's
why I chose the word confronting because
that's what it feels like we're doing
all the time with the professionals that
I work with in my role as an extension
scientist okay so I have a couple of
words to work through today obviously
confronting is the way I feel much of my
work both in research and extension goes
and because I'm not a government
scientist I can still say climate change
this is quite a big joke in Canada I can
tell you and urban grass lands right
many of you know I like many of the
people who do what I do around the
country
you know the turf guy in in Nebraska the
turf guy in Wisconsin I've been the turf
guy in New York and now I'm have to
figure out how to make something cool
out of urban grasslands because that
seems to be their trendy term so let's
look at the what what I want to cover
with you in a little bit of time that we
have here's how I've organized my work
and how I view the situation honestly
when you hear the word grasslands it
might it might hearken you to the
savannas the great savannahs of Africa I
think when you say urban grasslands my
sense is this is what most people think
that somehow they think it must be a
prairie we get to have in the city and
again you know the idea that this isn't
a managed landscape you know is sort of
ridiculous if you're going to have it
where there's people it's going to have
to be managed and I spend my entire
career working with the people stuck
with these things and being asked now to
sequester more carbon or reduce their
emissions or protect water quality when
no one was sort of worried about it in
the past so
in a bit of a pickle having to convince
the industry the actual front lines of
this mitigating the issues of climate
change when I think when the lion's
share of the people in urban
environments think about grasslands this
must be what they think this is the
beautiful Bethpage State Park 1,500
acres nestled in literally the center of
Long Island or I've spent a lot of time
researching and studying I consider this
an urban grassland even though I mean of
course you can see the development
around there but I assure there's houses
all over there soccer complex outside of
Boston you know in a typical Saturday
this is an urban grassland ok obviously
from the early days of Levittown in the
40s right we now have landscapes that
you know connect each other by these
close cut and vegetative surfaces in
front of their dwellings this is
grassland and one of the things that's
fascinating when you study it as an
academic you know you read so much about
the influence that the humans have on
the things that we have to do to produce
these grasslands and the study of
behavior of how people care for their
lawns in particular oftentimes and has
been shown in several studies to be very
much related to mimicry they call it you
know I think in casual terms recall
keeping up with the Joneses or you know
not having a lawn that looks worse than
somebody else but it's it's our own form
of mimicry we want in general to have
our space to look like everybody else's
how else could you tolerate some of
these living conditions so living that
closer to each other so where is the
grass where are the urban grasslands
well you can imagine by their name
they're in the urban areas and you can
see all along Long Island the
metropolitan New York area a little bit
that thinks it's part of New York and
then up the Hudson Valley to Albany
Utica Syracuse Buffalo Rochester you can
see it very clearly in our state but of
course throughout the United States you
see where the great grasslands are and
because they're urban they're typically
associated with impervious surface right
this is the story from the NASA spectral
work that Milesi did many years ago back
in 2005 where they looked at the
spectral cover and said you know this as
much there's as much turf area as there
is irrigated corn that's a bit of a
misnomer not all turf is irrigated not
all the turf you're looking at there is
irrigated as as all the irrigated corn
is but the relationship between where
grass is and how we manage it right is
ultimately the the challenges that I
face working with the people who manage
these grasslands you cannot separate
yourself from people in my line of work
as much as I'd like to and for you know
I love the day I get to work with an
apple farm somebody just you know get to
drive 30 miles to see one I got to drive
30 miles to see another nope
and because the end user is so
intimately associated with the surface
right I mean when you sell an apple or a
bottle of cider unless you're the farmer
you don't get direct feedback from the
people who you are dealing with in my
line of work you get more feedback than
you'd ever want to get from the public
and so you have to learn how to filter
and we have to learn as and I have to
learn as an extension scientist what are
the pressures that the people that I'm
working with are under from the people
that they're there and where are they
and how do we set a system that they can
somewhere meet in between between what
the public wants and needs right and the
management of these surfaces has to
adapt to now with the changing climate
so the people put enormous influence on
this lots of great pictures you know and
preparation for this I read a whole
bunch of work that's gone on throughout
the world
with things like reduction in crime
associated with you know just keeping
the place nice keeping it occasionally
clipped doesn't have to be manicured
like center field of Yankee Stadium but
if it's well-kept there's plenty of
evidence to show that these green
landscapes promote good behavior I don't
know what else to say it there's this
there's this policing idea that we
follow an American police work it's
called a broken window approach where
you stop these little crimes and then
supposedly not supposed to stop the big
ones and that sort of mentality in urban
areas has penetrated into the landscape
and so they need stuff really literally
broken all over the place lots of
important benefits of course easily
defined through the Millennium Project
my colleague my colleague Jenny Gao -
and grant Thompson published a wonderful
paper really a very of those papers that
will probably get cited for the next
3040 years you know integrating basic
ecological concepts and ecosystem
service stuff into the management of
these grasslands I of course stole
liberally from my colleagues like any
good colleague but we'll pay them the
proper credit but this mindset is one
that I've been sort of waiting for from
my own perspective because I believe the
approach that we have to have in these
urban environments is define the value
of these green spaces these green
infrastructures grasses or otherwise for
the services they provide because I hate
to say it we don't eat it we are blind
to the plants around us in urban areas
plant blindness is a normality people
don't see plants and when they do they
only see them when they're very pretty
like perfect lawns or weedy lawns and
then they have put them they imply that
mimicry judgment on it and so we get
caught up in this one little bit here
everything's fussing about this one
little bit my entire industry is focused
on 80% of the time this one word I'm not
kidding you and so what about all these
other things that are important
and how this vegetation services of the
urban areas and why I'm worried about it
is because when you look at what
happened in California recently as a
result of the drought last couple years
they just started paying people to rip
grass out they paid over thirty forty
million dollars paying people to take
their grass out I'll show you what they
put in in a minute but you know the
green industry out there was completely
ill-prepared golf courses were taking
money like crazy they were paying on a
per square foot basis just to take the
irrigated grass out up to which I said
well what the hell was it there to begin
with why was it there if you could take
it out that easy just for money why was
it there to begin with that's part of
the problem that we have now because
we're intimately linked to sociological
things and human behavior I feel like
some time while I'm getting my IRB
certification now finally and we're
gonna start doing more human surveys on
these things and so here's a pretty
classic Gallup question they've been
asking since the eighties this is the
last 17 years but since the 1980s and
when you and well I'm sorry this is not
that this is the one from the 80s ah
there's the data sorry
I had these a missile which of the
following do you agree with protection
of the environment should be given
priority even if curbing of economic
growth should be or or at the risk of
curbing economic growth or economic
growth should be given priority even if
the environment suffers so what do you
value the environment or your pocketbook
and it looked like for a really long
time through much of the 80s and 90s and
you'll notice this was a period of good
economic times when people aren't
worried about the money that goes in
their pocket they tend to value things
like environmental quality it's a pretty
normal behavior and you can see when the
end of that bubble happened and all the
bubbles and blips and booms we've had in
our economy over the last two decades
you can see how over that period of time
how
much people saying listen I gotta have
money the environments gonna have to
suffer a little bit you wonder how this
guy okay and I can take he for making a
joke so I'm happy to do it
we gotta stop taking ourselves so
seriously about this okay
so this Danish these are these Dutch
scientists Dirksen at all just recently
was looking at public acceptance and you
know asked citizens in the Netherlands
in in Rotterdam you know where they
value about the vegetation and green
space so certainly what they call green
infrastructure of which close vegetated
surfaces make up a big part so they
proposed this idea of how the sort of
process you have to follow to get people
to understand how to accept essentially
ecosystem services for the plants in the
urban environment if we can get the
public to demand these things from their
municipalities they will get done but as
we continue to just promote aesthetics
the the way we adapt to climate change
will be very difficult to accomplish so
what is the value of these green spaces
there the notion of climate impacts
concern about impacts rating green
infrastructure benefits what kind of
green infrastructures do you like and
how much you willing to pay for that
green infrastructure and so the question
that came out of that that they're
trying to see the services that they
value from the paper and they asked them
to rate which ecosystem services do you
value the most and in the various areas
right they were given opportunity so in
my line of work right you see them value
stormwater management right go with that
and recreational visually attractive so
at least I got you have to cut the grass
to play soccer on it you can't play it
in the meadow well that's all well and
good in the Netherlands this is the
people I did these are the people I have
to deal with on a
pretty regular basis when asked do you
believe which you know I don't like
using that word makes it turns it into a
sort of religious thing change global
warming is affecting golf course
maintenance and the largest percentage
of them say no climate changes croc this
is 2060 this is the audience that I'm
working with I know what your audiences
are like Steven you know Greg and
everybody else is extension audiences
this is my extension that's right so one
of the things we try to do and we
started this a year ago I've been very
fortunate to have in such an excellent
communications professionals boat and
Craig and in my assistant cross command
P we started this Twitter page over 1300
followers now we get a lot of regular
interaction this just-in-time media just
focused on getting them information
promoting you know the right thing to do
when if they given the right thing to do
at the time they need to do it they're
more likely to do it so this
just-in-time
way of delivering information is perfect
for the kinds of things I've got to deal
with in my extension so urban grasslands
the benefits of them obviously ecosystem
services is the way I think we would
quantify them but a difficult nut to
crack and lots of things working against
us in many ways
so let's talk a little bit about urban
climate change I don't know that it's
entirely different than what's going to
happen in other areas except the
extremes might be different because of
the amount of impervious surfaces right
and you know infrastructure that's there
generally I'm sure you've heard from RT
Gaetano anybody talks about climate
change that we're expecting a increase
and we have seen more heavy rain events
generally we have not overall been that
much wetter
year-to-year and of course the season
lengths are changing right when the
Frost's comes how hard the winter is and
I think when you put the word urban in
front of climate change it gets people
all worked up because
when it rains a lot it's not like a farm
field the screen into a ditch
there's a lot of paved surfaces and it's
got to move water great distances and if
it's not designed to do that which many
of the systems are not designed to do
that because they were designed before
we had this kind of weather you know
they're old and they need to be rebuilt
so I look at urban as well as you know
the heat island effect and more intense
storms many of the things you talked
about with climate change in general I
think in urban areas when you look at
the literature on urban climate change
it almost entirely focuses on how
there's a lot of people and a lot of
infrastructure at risk
urban areas put on a disproportional
amount of pressure on green space right
because they need it for the things that
are necessary to survive in an urban
environment you have to have plants in
those environments or at least have
plants around those environments to
service those apply so lots of poor
people of course and you know countries
that are not as fortunate as ours also
are going to suffer more greatly I think
all right we will obviously we want to
make sure the grass is covered so you
know the soil doesn't move longer
seasons mean our recreational surfaces
get a lot more traffic and this has made
synthetic turf very popular and I'm not
even going to open up that can of worms
that would be an entire another
presentation about the pits and perils
and perceptions of synthetic turf and
and where plays a role and and where it
can be dangerous and now we have pretty
good data on that but one of the things
that allows even poor communities to
have good playing surfaces is when they
do a capital project at a school
district the state of New York for
example will pay 85 cents on every
dollar and the local community only has
to come up with 15% so they get a
synthetic turf field for a hundred and
fifty thousand dollars while the state
pays the other eight hundred and fifty
thousand now of course we all pay for
that but that's one of the reasons
you're starting to see more synthetic
turf as well because when these
scholastic seasons happen the grass
isn't growing look how many of us watch
them plow snow and play lacrosse on the
synthetic turf they do it pretty
regularly through the winter around here
all right
urban climate change you know you have a
lot of urban areas here in the Northeast
and this is an example of this past
February the drought like conditions we
were entering the growing season with
right entering the growing season with
big pockets we had some pretty dry
weather a couple of years ago here in
the Finger Lakes and made it into the
red status a couple of times into
extreme droughts
I love these NOAA maps I use them all
the time with my industry every time
they see me talk and I'm talking about
growing something or we're having an
update on something they're gonna get an
updated map of what's going on because I
think it's very hard for people to
realize we've been keeping weather
records at least by human standards a
pretty long time 122 years not by you
know other timescales but by our ability
to do it many of these were handwritten
of course back then for a very long time
and consistently over the last decade
you're looking at record warm
temperatures sometimes incredibly dry
conditions so I think it's a when I say
confronting climate change
I tell people look what's happening
don't listen to me here's a data because
people that have trouble getting their
arms around climate change to begin with
for whatever you know reason that might
be right
eventually the data is compelling unless
we fire everybody at NOAA except our we
got a key part and of course I'm sure
you've seen this from any of the climate
reports that if this continues unabated
and we're starting to see it now when
you look at lengths of growing seasons
the metropolitan New York area is slowly
creeping into Philadelphia Lane it's
slowly starting to get growing
conditions like we're seeing in
Philadelphia when it comes to the
grasses in these urban environments in
these urban environments
and of course in these urban
environments with the impervious surface
you get the heat island effect and when
it rains to hutch floods for those of
you from downstate the Hudson River
Parkway very classic flooding conditions
on a pretty regular basis growing up
around there and yet there's green space
and I can tell you you could hit a
driver and probably beyond 50 off
courses around the Hutchinson River
Parkway over a 10 mile strip of the
Hutchinson River Parkway and not a
single one of those golf courses have
probably been approached to maybe help
with this problem and easily with some
manipulation of land they're doing this
in Chicago
they're going into the Park District's
and they're saying you know with
flooding like crazy now we built all
these houses we paved all this ground
how about we redesign this part of the
golf course make a big hole and put a
sister in it and they've done this on
three or four golf courses now in
Chicago someplace is just big collection
areas now the problem that that brings
is we let homeowners apply nutrients and
chemical pesticides to their laws this
is I don't this is this is a big problem
because you're talking about a sixty
five billion dollar industry
turf industry in the United States about
sixty five billion dollars and retail
sales of lord.and lawn and garden
supplies alone in 2014 almost six
billion and you see that the majority of
them are fertilizers and pesticides
right over 50% fertilizers and
pesticides not as much seed as we'd like
of combined so that means there's a lot
of products in the system that can be
spilled on those impervious surfaces
that can be applied to thin areas that
could drain and run if they're thin
right if you if you have good dense
vegetation even slow it'll it'll retain
and slow much of the water that will go
across
oh and Marnie Petrovic studied this many
years ago Zack Easton was a graduate
student here back in the early 2000s and
did these landscape-scale sampling
studies looking at runoff just water
runoff just the materia running off
these surfaces and low maintenance turf
that has very thin conditions one of the
things that's fascinating you see the
amount of runoff that actually occurs in
the winter and so well not a fully
covered ground the wooded areas Martie
talked about how the leaves wet leaves
seal up the surface and when the rain
was coming that water would run along
the surface and in this case where he
was maintaining with fertilizer and even
pesticides the water volume running off
that turf and it's not surprising right
this shouldn't be surprising grass is
fibrous root system big surface organic
matter a perennial crop at the surface
heck menial tell you if you mow it it'll
just grow you don't even need to do it
it is mow it and leave it alone so so if
it's death you know I would like to just
see some dense low-maintenance turf and
I know he didn't have good density when
he did this study now just to reinforce
the pesticide use issue this is data
from 2012 from the zipcodes surveys that
the all certified applicators of
pesticides in new york state private and
commercial have to report their
pesticide use by zip code and so this is
one of the only useful pieces of data
that's come out of the last 22 years of
that data collection that occasionally
they get around to putting these maps
out with pesticide use and of course if
you look at pesticide use you might
notice that there's an awful lot of
pesticide use in areas where there's not
a lot of farming going on not a lot of
farming going on here and of course you
could make the argument that some of
this is agriculture out here but that
sort of looks like Buffalo that sort of
look one of these is
one of these is missus Syracuse right so
so obviously even in courtly big big
agricultural region here
lots of pesticide use but this is a
concern the focus of pesticide use in
these urban areas where things can be
more mobile USGS surveys aren't expect
you to see this it's a just get an idea
of this is insecticide use and how it's
showing up in the streams that the USGS
is survey and you see a lot of it in
these urban areas mixed land-use areas
here's all the urban areas right and
some of them had the highest 25% right
is 25% insecticide concentration in the
streams so we got data that says if you
keep the turf in good shape
it might not release the products but
when you put it on in a large scale
there's got to be some exponential
effect from little bits here and there
I'm very suspicious that we contribute
to this because obviously rodenticides
and other insecticides this is just
insecticides but we use insecticides for
you know pets I don't know if that's a
big deal but obviously this is I would
think from a lot of landscape use which
drives people crazy people go nuts they
show up in meetings you ever been in a
meeting where somebody dresses like that
and your jobs supposed to stand up and
talk to them about reasonable pesticide
use so so what I learned is you cannot
talk to these people you have to talk to
these people
because they can talk to these people
right and so we got to slow down use but
we got nuts over here that's you know we
can't reason with and so it just feels
like it pulls the whole debate and I can
tell you as a modern extension
scientists in an urban area dealing with
these issues no one wants to see me
because you know to certain extent I
help them and then aggravate them and I
help these people and then I a great and
I almost feel
maybe that's the role in these
contentious sociological things that
someone has to sort of mediate it and I
think it's sort of a progressive role
for modern extension anyway what about
worse dreams
here's some I don't sure everybody's the
environmental community's been paying
attention to this but this came out in
2014 the province on Ontario of Ontario
and Canada banned all pesticide use on
homeowners so you cannot go to Home
Depot or any of the places and use you
can't buy pesticides for laws and and
commercial lawn care people can't apply
synthetic pesticides they're using iron
they're using Emma toads they're using
fungus you know fungi for you know
antagonistic biocontrol things much of
what's happened is they've actually the
lawn services are selling more cultural
practices they're getting better lawns
by seating them to good varieties and
fixing the soil and that's what banning
chemicals has done the other the other
thing that banning chemicals have done
and I don't expect you to see the
details of this but these are the three
major components of the typical
broadleaf herbicide used in turf three
active ingredients to 4d everybody's
buddy these days died kamba and mecha
prop right and the dark bars are these
whisker plots right so Unitas works this
is 50% of the data and then the wider
areas and then where they're
significantly different and the dark bar
let's just focus in on the die camba in
this particular stream so they sampled
all these streams and you see in almost
every case not always statistically
significant but most of the time the
back before the band's the concentration
of the materials in the stream before
the ban and after the ban they are all
dropping now these things move out of
the environment a little bit quicker
than phosphorous does right you you're
dealing with legacy phosphorous you
don't see these we're not seeing these
reductions in phosphorous as a result of
fertilizer phosphorous bans in urban
we're not seeing that reduction and I
still think it's because we got to sweep
the street every day nobody wants to
hear that and paved surfaces to drain
into the drain and then they go into the
rivers
so just because we're here so we've are
confronted this I would say particular
issue of water quality as a result of
these intense rains and public concern
for pesticide use to develop these best
management practices for golf courses
that serve as codifying the standards
golf courses can be held in for water
quality protection and now I've gone
completely insane and maybe working with
the landscape industry in especially in
downstate New York which most of them
are of my nationality so it creates
quite an interesting dynamic when you
have to tell them to do things that they
have absolutely no interest in doing but
they are science-based standards that we
hope ensure the highest level of water
quality protection and I put this in
there you know if you don't maintain a
landscape that someone will pay for you
can't be in the landscaping business and
that business and industry is not going
away they're going to keep existing so
we have to figure out how to meet them
in this and it's not going to be it's
not gonna be so easy
all right reducing emissions this is
funny I put a bunch of students together
back in 2007 and then in 2008 we
published the study that we did we just
took and interviewed about 15 golf
courses throughout New York State and
asked them about their fertilizer and
chemicals and mowing programs we got
averages for what the average golf
course in New York State would emit in
carbon emissions now we didn't look at
nitrogen emissions that I'll talk to
about talk to you about in a minute
but we didn't look at anything but
carbon and the question was can a golf
course be carbon neutral so we took our
survey information and applied it to
what the GCS a a the Goff
superintendent's Association of big
association in the Midwest says the
average golf course in the United States
is so the average golf course about 150
acres you can see very little in the
cutting surfaces and teeing ground
most of it is in fairways and rough on a
percentage basis right so most of the
chemical and fertilizer treatments are
confined to these three areas and around
here mostly to the greens in the central
New York area in particular so we looked
at direct energy consumption did some
calculations based on carbon equivalents
for the various energy units we had all
these units and not we'd have any
coal-fired equipment but we had all the
other ones and so we had a way of
calculating based on their fuel use and
the kind of fuel it was and then we
started looking at the way they mode and
this is some work that taught the total
company did and we looked at it as well
in this case this is a mowing power
mower with a GPS device on it and they
either collected the clippings off the
fairway or didn't we can talk about how
much longer it takes the more fair way
to put these pretty stripes in it that's
about three times the carbon emission as
simply driving long ways right just
driving long way then a farmer will tell
you that because you spend most of your
time turning and when you dump the
clippings it adds about an hour to the
mow time yeah well you know if you're mo
fairways you're in no rush to get off
that piece of equipment as frequently as
yes so you tend to take your time do so
we finished putting robotic mowers we're
going to go crazy with this we've got
four of these guys running around mowing
day or night the proper amount or too
much and we're going to try to see if we
can build the crude elements of a smart
system by integrating irrigation sensors
into this because I don't believe people
can be trusted to manage their lives now
if we start plugging everything in then
we've got different issues and we've
talked to the industry nationally about
this
where does your power come from all
right if everybody starts plugging their
cars in and we're burning more coal or
burning other fossil fuels I'm not
entirely sure that helps us completely
so we've done a lot of edge
Kayson just hey guys think about where
your power comes from you know if you
start plugging in more and more things
and you're in Idaho where 93 percent of
your power is hydroelectric well maybe
that's not a bad thing to plug more
things
there's also embodied energy in the on
the golf course carbon equivalents
that's associated with nutrient use of
macronutrients in particular and the
ranges of materials that we can get from
West's work this is not the easiest
thing to do and the range you see is is
very dramatic sometimes we have the
active ingredients carbon equivalents
many times we use the average right
because it's very not all the active
ingredients have been assessed for the
carbon equivalents associated with their
manufacture so we put this rule together
we did it against our Bethpage project
years ago where we had where we were
spraying less pesticides so you'll see
in general the numbers are the same
except we cut our fertilizer use
dramatically in our IPM program now
interestingly the pesticide use went up
but a lot of these are softer materials
Omri certified materials but they're
still our pesticide so it gave us a big
number and obviously the biggest
reduction we saw was in fertilizer use
in that particular management now not
really interested in the different types
of management we looked at roughly the
equations you'd use for look at the
amount of carbon sequestered on the golf
course
an average golf course in a season and
then roughly what we would emit from
from carbon not not the nitrogen
component and that was the weaknesses
preliminary work anyway so you you saw a
slight reduction maybe about four or
five tons per tons of carbon equivalents
per year a u.s. auto is about 3.6 so you
know of course at least at least the way
we measured it this first time is not
necessarily problematic from a carbon
perspective but I think the total
greenhouse gas thing I'm going to show
you a different
um actual science done on it not a
student project but actual science we've
also been studying emerging pests I
published a paper with our D Gaetano
back in 2006 where we looked at the
increasing disease pressure associated
with the changing climate so we had a
model that predicts fungal infection of
turf and we ground Trude it to
diagnostic labs in the Northeast so that
for a couple of years we were you know
looking at our model and seeing if it
was predicting it where we were testing
it and then checking diagnostic labs if
regionally we were on target
and we use this in our extension program
in our forecasting and moving towards
push notifications for when risks of
disease go up so hoping to get that kind
of thing added but it's all predicated
on the environmental conditions
conducive to the disease so we knew what
the conditions were art went back in
scanned the 50 years of data to see if
we're getting any more of and this is
what happens when you do no pesticide
work on a golf course where they've been
spraying pesticides for 50 years and
what you notice in this slide is all
these black dots are where we reviewed
the weather and found that the weather
conditions are increasing for the
incidence of this disease in the last 50
years in fact the model even picked up
something we've been observing now for
the last decade that we're seeing more
of this fungal pathogen pressure in the
late fall than we used to see so we are
definitely at least with this pest
seeing big big changes and that requires
us to spray more at a time when the
public is less interested in a spray
this is my our most recent venture the
Greenwood Cemetery in Brooklyn probably
I hope I hope I can study out there for
the rest of my career and into my
retirement because some of the things I
want to do can really only be done in a
commercial setting first you sometimes
the public won't really understand that
if it can't be sort of done in a
commercial way and
and scale down I think they're going to
accept robot mowers we're gonna try
robot motors out here
but the problem Greenwood Cemetery is
having doesn't seem like a big deal but
that's Zoe grass that started to be it
was about three acres by general
estimation about five or six years ago
and now it's close to eight acres
covering the cemetery and that has to be
directly related especially in the last
few years with the very very warm
winters zoycha japonica is a imported
Voyager species to this country
naturalized for turf throughout the
United States and planted cold hardy
varieties planted north and they are
pretty good when they're green which is
two and a half months three months a
year and when you're in a cemetery the
most important day of the year is
Mother's Day Mother's Day and this grass
is straw brown on Mother's Day and it's
growing in population now our question
is chemically we can spray it and
intercede into it some of the landscapes
are tricky to do that in I'm wondering
if we can't have a mixed warm season
cool season grass mixture of c3 and c4
plants in your lawn this has happened I
was in st. Louis last week and I visit
that area particularly because I'm
interested in the transition zone where
you watch climate change in action the
line of where Bermuda grass can grow
rights i know domme keeps creeping up
and creeping up about five to ten miles
a year the guys will tell you yeah that
guy used to add Bermuda now he's you
know or he used to have Bank grass now
he's got Bermuda because it's too warm
now can't keep the cool season grass all
right I'll wrap it up sorry for I hope
make it right to the ten mark how do we
maximize the benefits and minimize the
impacts to me from my perspective if I
can get a decent answer to that question
I'll feel like we're closer to
sustainability than we were before
and let's be fair the amount of inputs
we use for the grasses sometimes is the
problem we get the same amount of
benefits in many cases without a lot of
inputs without a lot of inputs so the
what we need and of course this is the
trendy thing right there these resilient
landscapes these landscapes that can
take these cold and warm conditions dry
and wet conditions this is what they did
with the lawns in California and you
know what's funny this was right after
they were planted no water was put in
here how long do you think those plants
left what's the over-under maybe three
weeks but before they admit they were
actually dead but they didn't pull him
out probably for six months and
companies ran around California taking
money doing this and then now they live
in the Caymans so how do you affect this
kind of change and so the first thing
you do is you get to the architects
because many of them design the
landscape is late landscape said look on
our paper other things look good on
paper and then managing them and the
benefits that they provide so a number
of years ago I had another group of
students and I don't know if this has
ever actually become part of the sites
initiative but the sites initiative
sustainable sites initiative I'm sure
you've heard Nena maybe Don other people
talk about this collection of standards
it's basically the lead system that the
US Green Building Council uses that idea
for landscapes how we build landscapes
that are sustainable and the first go at
this they said no grass for you Frank
well if you had grass in your landscape
you could not be viewed as a sustainable
site all right I think hopefully they
changed it a little bit and here's what
we proposed first of all we want to get
old grasslands to require minimum energy
water and chemical inputs for their
intended use while supporting outdoor
exercise so design
points activity point design activity
points they support no community
activity that just for look passive
recreation picnicking walking okay a
little bit of traffic and then supports
athletic activities this is the kind of
thing we've got to get people to
understand and of course you see this in
action when you go to a place like
Central Park where they've prioritized
the lawns they've got intensely traffic
soccer fields and the sheep's meadow and
then another area where it's fenced off
and no one goes in and other areas where
the dogs go and there's very little
grass the other part is the ecology how
do we put this together what we're using
it for with the benefits it provides
right sites designed for require
maintenance for any low usage area you
get if you have to high maintain just
for aesthetic purpose is an area that
doesn't get used much you get no points
for that to for moderate maintenance
right and we put some other things in
here and it comes up with an equation
now this may seem goofy to you but this
is the world people who build things
live it and if we can get them thinking
like this at the front and the
management of these landscapes are
inherently more focused and sustainable
when they've started to study this is
happening more and more now they've
studied how do how can I urban grassland
reduce a mission and increase carbon
sequestration so Erin Patton at Purdue
University had a graduate student that
looked at this and this isn't that study
this is a study of sort of how you have
to fertilize Kentucky bluegrass to keep
the weeds out but that's aesthetics
right except that this is awful thin and
maybe the runoff will be bad but if you
seeded it and maybe more grass would
emerge so if you want the lowest
emissions that managing turf can give um
there's a you can plant Kentucky
bluegrass never to foliated more than
30% and return the clippings all right
let's get back now if you want the
greatest carbon accumulation you plant
tall fescue
rapidly growing rapidly organic matter
producing species the foliated 30
percent of the times returned the
clipping so it's right now these are the
pieces of data we've got we've got a
long way to go in terms our approach
with the homeowner is the lawn care
stuff I wonder if I'm gonna skip right
to it so sorry for the delay sorry to
keep you so don't feel like if you gotta
go you can't go I'm happy to stay and
answer questions like you're saying that
I guess I'm wondering what your fingers
for the barriers to homeowners these
issues so so it seems to me the question
is how do we get homeowners to look at
their lawn beyond just what it looks
like it's right I mean what I would tell
you is just make sure it's densely
vegetated right now that's the best data
we've got that even if you have what you
don't want is a lot of annual weeds that
come and go but if you can maintain a
perennial vegetation that's a collection
of we broad leaves and grassy plants and
they're dense we're good the problem is
there's you know this is a big cultural
thing and I can I could write a whole
paper on just the cultural things about
this but you know the parents did it
it's one of those things that we still
can't let go from Leave It to Beaver and
I also think that you know Scott's plows
a lot of money Scott's alone is a three
billion dollar company so so it's a like
many things in a capitalist society we
have industry an industry sometimes
drives
option just like you know pictures in
magazines drive the cosmetic industry
you see you see a pretty baseball field
or a beautiful golf course I want that
now I can tell you that's a shrinking
proportion of the population it looks
like the next generation could give to
whatever for their lawn just because
they got so much they don't have a lot
of time to take care of it that's the
big thing time becomes a bigger
commodity that that how do we break
through it's a tough thing because we're
not well funded with a marketing program
you know our our lawn website gets about
1400 hits a day in April and May 1400
and that's nothing compared to what guys
who make goofy videos on YouTube about
lawns yes Mike the insects the insect
yeah in terms of like so yeah so right
so the question about ticks in these
landscapes you know we don't know Mike
there was some suggestions that and it's
and generally we see it but not as a
rule that mowed lawns where deer don't
frequent and lay and you know because
it's a fairly dry environment out there
generally aren't big havens but ecotones
the edges are enormous because they're
all sitting there like it's a it's the
gladiators right that they breathe they
see all the carbon dioxide out there
with the people right but then are going
out there because it's something
inhospitable to them unless they get on
a deer they get on a deer then they're
in your lawn it's a little bit trickier
to get on you unless you're a little
person and you're going your bare feet
in your onesie now you're a little bit
more even on a lawn a little bit more at
risk but no definitive population we
don't have enough ecological data to say
yet what's going on but we know for sure
they're at the wood lines around the
lawns in enormous lehigh populations as
we'd expect after a master
[Music]
of course right that's what all the
studies yeah of course of course right
[Music]
that's good advice
I think this is basically saying it has
no there's no community
your point is well think we should give
that place for sure yes yeah we made it
this isn't for real no no they won't let
us we proposed this to them and we put
it in the format to send it to them but
I still don't does but not this stuff
yeah no but did they take the points
approach which we propose they did okay
good so maybe we should look to see so
if they giving it a zero we should
probably go back and fix it okay thank
you very much this has been a production
of Cornell University on the web at
cornell edu